yes
happy someday of the week again i forgot
we got another humdinger of a program
what's a humdinger who the hell knows i
had one removed earlier this week
thank god for solid tongs
it's funny how i managed to sit on
things
accidentally of course
joining us tonight is matt whitaker
very
very athletic man very athletic man i
just got off a grueling workout
yeah he a little known fact he shares a
birthday with our very own cat
proving once and for all that astrology
is about as real as joy behar's hair
also joining us
julie pantera
glad to see her here
given her antics last night
drew truly is something else she'll
drink all your rose as well as your rose
b and your rosie
speaking of a jumble of chaos and
confusion how about gensake
in an effort to play the race and the
gender card she ended up throwing her
administration under the bigoted bus
following a cnn report on the
dysfunction in the vice president's
office saki told politico it all comes
down to you guessed it sexism and racism
there's no question
she is the first uh african-american
woman one of color um indian american
woman to serve in this job woman i mean
so many firsts right it's a lot to have
on your shoulders she is somebody who
um at a much higher level than the rest
of us but who wants to be seen as the
talented experienced um you know
expert
substantive policy person partner to the
president that she is um but you know i
do think there has been um some attacks
that are beyond um because of her
identity
so to quote the tsa agent who works the
x-ray machine and spotted those objects
in the shape of a summer squash and a
melon ball scooper over the weekend
let's unpack this
the long way for a butt joke
cnn had reported this growing infighting
as an exclusive story meaning it came
from the white house now maybe cnn could
have just made it up like the russian
collusion crap but this story had too
many integral facts coming from too many
sources fact is if the white house wants
a story out there all it has to do is
pick up biden's sports illustrated
football phone and it's on cnn faster
than stelter's pudgy fingers on a
powdered donut
so
i'll take it
so when saki claims that some attacks on
harris are based on her identity she's
actually referring to the very criticism
that came from the white house meaning
joe and his staff are having a problem
with women of color they're the white
supremacists huh
how does that feel joe
turn about his fair play after your
written house smear remember joe went to
a funeral for a grand cyclops which is
not a person with a zit in the middle of
their forehead
it's the title of a higher up in the kkk
as in democrat robert byrd
he probably didn't even check his watch
during that funeral
joe also made fun of indians before
observing that they only work in
7-elevens remember that
so jen
has to be talking about joe but it's
hard to tell since jen unloads more crap
than joe biden after three bowls of all
bran
i know that's another poop reference
was that too much phyllis
greg made a couple of more poop jokes
tonight is it too far no it's not i love
his poop girls when he tells him they
are so great i love him
can't argue with phyllis
she's a national treasure
so whatever there's a problem with these
clowns it has to be because we're all
racist and sexist right it's never about
their incompetence or callousness or
loathing for average working-class
americans which is just another form of
bigotry a coal miner could finish a
10-hour workday covered in soot and
they'd call him out for blackface
this is really about the vp in turmoil
which is the only kind of oil this
administration will allow
time for the next chapter of
in search of
kamala harris
[Music]
with your host
sarah jessica hartman
it has been a tough search so far but
thankfully we were able to catch up with
her earlier today yes we scored an
exclusive one-on-one interview
welcome to the show madam vice president
thanks greg it's great to be here i love
your show especially the blonde girl
although she could use a sandwich
preferably a toasted one made with toast
using a
toaster i have to say uh you do look
like a toaster i am a toaster you
what did you expect to have a human
actually impersonate her because if they
did impersonate her they'd be called a
racist and a sexist nobody wants to play
kamala because they're scared
of being cancelled so it's just better
to have a
toaster wait you can't cancel a toaster
the only problem is unlike kamala
toasters actually do their job you know
i got to ask you to watch the language
this is after all a family show
okay mr obsessed with poop oh here comes
the poop joke
poop poop poop can you just stop for one
minute and what's with the non-stop drug
jokes about kat
she is a wholesome
loving healthy person with a strong
moral character
you though are a flaming
that boy sounds really familiar
all right all right let's just get down
to this what do you think of jen saki
saying that it's all sexism and racism
behind the criticism that's being
directed at you miss harris
do i know i'm a toaster go ask a
microwave ah
well thanks for joining us
what did you expect do you think we'd
really get an actual person to
impersonate kamala harris we tried to
talk harris faulkner into it but she
said dinner at fuddruckers wasn't enough
fact is you can impersonate anyone
except the protected classes designated
by the legacy media as if there's on a
do not disturb list remember when snl
forced poor fred armisen to impersonate
obama and they made him so incredibly
boring so it was not to offend anyone
it's really the worst insult we don't
think you can take the criticism which
allows some of the biggest crooks to get
away with anything hell some can even
marry their brother
i don't know who i'm talking about so it
comes down to this when in trouble smear
the others when in doubt call the bigots
out call him racist call him sexist but
never call for the truth it's the
difference between this white house and
the previous one who did trump go after
the media china the nba the nfl
democrats and republicans celebrities he
punched up not down he didn't single out
citizens or voters
here the white house sees you the
individual as the problem and they see
group identity as its protection it's a
racket they're the victims even when
they're in power and you're not
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guest
in college he caught passes now he
knocks lids on their asses for rafting
attorney general matt whitaker
she's more buzzed than a bee shaving
with an electric razor fox news anchor
julie benderez
he has crowds lined up at the box office
asking about the refund policy writer
and comedian joe devito
and finally her teachers encourage her
to run with scissors boxes contributors
no julie i used to think you were the
biggest hot female mess i ever met
but actually
kamala harris is more of a mess than you
are i actually really can relate to the
story because i too lead a life
entrenched in dysfunction yes
lack of
focus
[Laughter]
but honestly i think it's a it's a lame
card to play when you play the race card
here i've said and i've maintained this
from the very beginning i believe joe
biden picked her so that he would be the
first president to put a woman in the
vice president position correct but i
think as far as her ability to do the
job i mean being a woman should be an
advantage to her because unlike men we
can multitask so that would mean that
there is absolutely no excuse for her
sucking at her job that is like that was
a jab at uh men
uh
i mean i i mean i get it you got to cook
you got to clean you got to walk
i do none of the other sexist would say
that yeah but i'm not saying that right
i do none of the above for the record my
husband does all of that so maybe that's
why you're a mess or why i wear the
pants
literally which aren't very clean at
this point no they're not no they're not
matt welcome to the show i always enjoy
being on here thank you
um
do you think they're actually defending
her i mean it seems like no this is
trying to get her out and to some extent
uh you know she is the first at many
things including having the lowest
approval rating of any vice president at
this point in time yeah so you know i
know you like math the real question is
who's your ears is is joe is joe biden
pushing kamala harris's favorability
down or is she pulling him down that's
the uh chicken and the egg question
exists
right now they appear to be blaming her
yeah exactly yeah it is true they're
both in trouble so they're blaming it's
you it's not me it's you they're like
those dueling spider-mans they should
have her look at the root causes of his
lack of favorability
yeah she's the root cause of her lack of
favorability
they don't like me joe you're used to
that um
do you when they say there's no rift do
you believe them
they better hope there's a rift between
kamala and jill biden because she's
ready to cut her yeah
slash her up with a scalpel she was a
real doctor
[Laughter]
they're still mad about what happened to
the debates maybe it was a bad idea to
pick your running mate to be someone who
called you a segregationist over your
opinions on bussing yeah let's come back
because now 40 years later he's throwing
her under the bus so it's come full
circle
nice
this this is what annoys me so much is
that they put so much stake in identity
yeah you know and they say and the
people in the left say things like isn't
it time
for a woman of color to be considered
for president and you say okay well how
about condoleezza rice like whoa look at
the time it's not quite the time for
someone like that
so it's so easy to go for these the
racism sexism but it's when you pick
identity over ability this is what you
end up with right right
little plus
chat uh i thought the interview with the
interview i did with the vice president
was very strange yeah
yeah
super weird yeah exactly very cold yeah
very steely yes yes but you didn't
cackle no you know what this but that's
this should prove your point that if you
take if you take this administration
with all their experience they're more
inept than an administration that had no
experience absolutely so you can't get
better at politics especially because
like jenn saki doesn't even realize how
sexist what she said was
uh i mean being a woman can be hard but
as a woman i am a woman by the way i
don't want people to think that i'm
going to be like totally
incapable of basic competency because
she literally said listen kamala would
be better at her job but she's a woman
so she can't
that's what she said she said woman
twice she's the first woman and just
just even as a woman like yeah like
that's way more offensive than a lot of
things i've heard yeah
and and also it's like she is the first
politician i've seen in history who
decided not to do the job that she was
told she went to the border and then she
just and then she just dropped kind of a
power move yeah like you know when i'm
done and i said this on the five it's
like it's she's worse than the cable guy
because the cable guy will be five hours
late but at least he'll fix it she just
went she didn't fix it and then she she
won't even return your calls like it's
like you didn't you never you know we
called you about the border
you you said you gave us a time between
12 and 7 p.m to be home to be home at
the border
and you never showed up she goes yeah
i'm on another call in france yeah yeah
but but you know greg the real challenge
in this situation is she had very little
experience to be vice president to fix
these problems joe biden had all the
experience right and he can't fix it
either so i mean it really is kind of
the you know again this you think that
all those years he helped create them
would give him an inside
yes
he's like alcohol he helped make the
problem that should help that old line
about alcohol joe biden is this
is of and the solutions to all of these
problems yeah there you go hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else